hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights or I'm gonna
find out what's in this door here
hopefully some oil Oh lovely no that
can't be David just why I'm sorry my
friend I don't even know who you are I I
don't even know chair block that door
for me please
thank you very much chair I don't even
know who you are
why were you up here this is like a
worse place to be whatever it don't
matter
well a key lab key mmm yeah nothing no
oil dick diddly why did you looking for
me I made this note on one of the last
days everyone was already dead and my
family well dot dot I drank the content
of the amnesia bottle I don't know why
and I didn't have enough time to think
because I was starving to death in this
terrible place this place is already a
hundred and fifty years old I don't know
how I came in here but one thing those
bad things you are seeing are just
illusions not real but they can hurt you
for some reason and they're not
illusions all the problems are leading
to one reason seamen he did all of this
bad things do the world a favor find him
and destroy him before the force is
getting released the force goodbye and
thank you for all your efforts and help
I apparently didn't help you at all cuz
you're dead from some weird malady of
the head looks like it alright anyway so
I got a key to the lab I'm assuming
that's the last key to get to the next
level
before so
let's go hello Andrew what was that well
it's like some level of darkness here
I was like moving right now was doing
anything this guy Oh cannot see okay
take him right then oh maybe this key is
to that door on the other side let me
try that first before I go downstairs
again because I would hate to come all
the way back up here after it was just
right in front of me okay come on
, stupid rocks up up up
hi anybody out there
come on work ah see that would have been
terrible try to go on the other way
all right now oh something to smash come
here oh yeah yeah badass breaking glass
nothing nothing no oil screw you then Oh
[ __ ] up wow that really flew huh that
didn't do anything
all right anything in here no it's the
pot of acid and oh it's a pot of acid
that's what I got the glass for so long
ago I remember ah
wait what where's tonic
I think that's an error some science
equipment very light I can light mmm
Bunsen burner know Nene knew nothing
okay Busan please test tube screw you we
finally we finally obtained the acid but
we have no container to place it in okay
I got it
what do I need it for some like block
didn't work
seriously can I combine
combination does not work screw you then
combination does not work well if your
face combination ISM yeah I got it the
first time
no momento
okay I've got the acid also known as
where's tonic which is from the original
amnesia if you forgot it was the thing
that allowed me to cut off his head and
push you through the portal I guess
that's it was the only reason I came
here for this acid we look at my notes
howdy some yo kids know it's hi David
um bum ba ba ba ba ba
Lux machine like that nope nope ah ba ba
ba ba no the instructions no that's
wrong okay this is all it's not helpful
at all okay I'm assuming there's nothing
else in here that I need therefore leave
I got the acid so let me let me try to
do something with the acid I'm still
gonna go in the dark because I want to
be more careful on about my oil
consumption is I don't think I was
supposed to run out here or maybe I was
in there just [ __ ] okay
what what I will get you prepared for
your door oh no oh no oh no oh no oh my
goodness oh my goodness oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
manages and
and Annika's cave-in mannequins
mannequin mannequin more mannequins or
mannequin mannequin hey what's up buddy
how you doing oh oh
this drum this is that room that I
didn't know what is for Oh back here oh
boy
holy [ __ ] are lost the dead kids dad
that's no good that's oh boy so what do
I do about this the oil in um okay do I
do about this hello ah oh no oh no you
don't lose man uh uh loose man I'm too
quick so pro and handsome what why is he
there okay
they're leading me for something drew
you crew you're in your face still by me
why is he right behind me I still hear
the music I still hear the music
I'm the closet yep
that was perfect I made it hey to do the
closet I don't know if this is supposed
to go but I made it
okay I don't think they followed me in
that farm how that door get rebuilt I
thought of another monster broke it down
okay I may not have been supposed to
come in here think I missed it
hello stop wasting oil pull yet so much
of that
hey hello
uh low that moose man I think it is
never heard that scraping something
that's definitely moose man he's always
blocked off right there he's literally
right there was he doing hey he's just
scraping on his he dad okay that's why I
can't I need to go around but he's doing
something
let me not look at him try to get around
him this will work perfectly he's gonna
work beautifully I just know it so Pro
watch this guy
oh my god just working that's the way
out
that's the way out the way out I made it
ha ha ha stop me oh okay
alright we got a pot of acid also known
as where's tonic and I don't know what
I'm gonna do with it but I've got it and
that's what's important so long as I've
got it alright I made it Wow
hoo boy I was a nice UI once again I
love the things disguise if that this
guy has done with varying the level
design using different techniques um
using things in interesting ways that
you wouldn't think of doing it before
that all of it I plot it I love it love
it big time
and now I assume those nothing right
those uh I assume I can go out into the
next level hey something about this
maybe I use the acid to melt away the
lock on the other thing maybe I do this
maybe I'll do that I don't know whatever
I'll find out Oh aha I'm gonna go up to
the lady and give it a big sloppy kiss
oh yeah yeah oh let's get a journal see
this must be the padlock that can't be
open but where is everybody I'm AHA okay
I got it I got it oh I see oil enough
there there
aw just like that didn't even name the
hammer and chisel it
oh yeah large oil oh that's so befitting
my status all right cool beans you're in
good shape
these stairs are hard to go up
apparently
like that New York subway the one step
is just a little bit higher than the
others very pretty very very nice
once again
I don't even know what these are from
but they're awesome oh and that is a
fairy
I'm chasing me no I must be getting
close to the end very interested
Oh yargh yargh was my gilding Wow
oh yeah I got it
I had heard when I read the description
that I thought they used some elements
from a number I don't know if I've seen
them already or what but I haven't seen
them yet haha
don't get get don't turn me towards it
oh there's nothing no what
that's something where the freaking
frack did that come from
what the hell it was like nothing
what oh hey uh I gotta keep running a
getting training just not door don't dad
dar dar dar oh man
oh boy can't appreciate the nice scenery
right now must run for life which way
over there problem door don't dick
around or barrel the block it block it
block it up good oh no I'm not gonna get
me take that
nope ah they're way behind me
Oh apical oh oh three six eight yeah
oh so pro Oh jump over the barrels go
over the barrels come over ah who's that
oh no oh oh ah okay
oh yeah I must be like it's much I'm
real close to the end here it is I want
to get the end in one episode if it is
yeah I think it'll be all right I really
do think I'm meeting close to the end
here so well I might be totally wrong
but it's only a mitad off of my normal
time so I think I think you guys can
forgive me right please please forgive
me anyway thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye